hola de nuevo bueno aquí yo tengo un
problemita bastante interesante dice lo
siguiente dice petatán michoacán está
ubicado directamente al oeste de la
palma michoacán
entonces supongamos que que aquí está
petatán entonces anpe está tan michoacán
está aquí petatán y el cual está al
oeste de la palma michoacán así que yo
voy a dibujar aquí una línea saco con la
herramienta de línea entonces una línea
horizontal si yo me dirijo directamente
al este yo podría llegar a la palma
michoacán ajá el cual está aquí está la
palma michoacán le pongo el nombre d
de g simplemente entonces aquí está
y bueno muy bien en una noche de neblina
un bote de pesca parte de petatán en un
curso de 105 grados entonces 105 grados
lo más lo más difícil de estos problemas
en mi opinión es averiguar la
comprensión que utilizan cuando dicen en
un curso de 105 grados bueno qué es eso
o sea que que es que es un curso am
entonces estuve yo investigando y en el
mundo de los botes un curso el curso que
toma son los grados o cuántos grados en
dirección de las manecillas del reloj
tomás y también tomando el norte como 0
grados entonces esto supongamos que
estos son los 0 grados y aquí está hacia
acá está el norte y el pescador se
dirige 105 grados en dirección de las
manecillas del reloj así que con
respecto a esto más o menos estaría por
aquí aquí ahora
en dirección de 105 grados entonces yo
dibujo esto eso representado en esta
línea rosa aquí está esto es 105 grados
ajá entonces en dirección de las
manecillas del reloj con respecto al
norte y cuánto es este ángulo visto de
una manera más familiar bueno esto sería
90 hasta aquí ajá y aquí sería 15 más 15
en términos de círculo en términos de
círculo unitario
esto sería menos 15 grados cierto o si
quisiéramos averiguar el ángulo de este
vértice esto sería 90 más otros 15
grados así que será cuánto esto será 15
grados porque su curso es de 105 90 más
15 de 105 esta línea azul es de va de
oeste a este
él se dirige como más hacia el hacia el
sureste cierto así que bueno sigo
leyendo el problema dice el parte de
petatán en un curso de 105 grados al
mismo tiempo que otro bote sale de la
palma en un curso de 195 grados 195° el
norte así
esto representa 0 grados y este otro
bote toma un curso de 195 grados y bueno
recuerda que hablamos de 195 grados en
dirección de las manecillas del reloj
con respecto al norte así que veamos
serán 180 hasta aquí y un poquito más
ajá más o menos por aquí entonces bueno
seminara algo así si vemos su y si
podemos averiguar cuánto vale este
ángulo este ángulo de aquí bueno creo
que ya más o menos ya veces a dónde se
dirige este problema tal vez queremos
averiguar el tamaño de todo este
triángulo la verdad es que aún no he
leído el programa completo así que estoy
adivinando ok
bueno estoy aquí es de 180 grados con
respecto a las manecillas del reloj de
estar arriba estamos directamente abajo
esto es 180
el toma un curso de 195 entonces esto
será de 15 grados 15 grados este ángulo
es de 15 grados ahora cuánto vale este
otro ángulo cuanto vale este ángulo
bueno hay es todo este ángulo vale 90
cierto es como el tercer cuadrante
cuando lo pensamos en término del ciclo
unitario en términos del círculo
unitario y entonces este ángulo será de
90 menos 15 grados cuánto es 90 menos 15
grados en 75 y si quisiéramos convertir
estos ángulos de curso al círculo
unitario en el ciclo unitario inicies
aquí y te vas todo alrededor en esta
dirección entonces esto sería como como
255 grados más o menos pero bueno en fin
ya sabemos que este ángulo vale 15 este
ángulo vale 75 ahora cuánto vale
este tercer ángulo los tres ángulos
deben sumar 180 entonces será 180 menos
15 menos 75 cierto 180 menos 15 menos 75
y bueno cuánto da eso es 180 menos 90 lo
cual también es 90 así que uaw este
ángulo es un ángulo recto eso
muy interesante eso está genial ahora
que más nos dice nos dice el primer bote
viaja a 23 nudos así que él viajó en
esta dirección 23 nudos en esta
dirección eso es un poco más un poco más
rápido que 23 millas por hora y se
colisionan con el segundo bote ahora la
pregunta es cuál era la velocidad
promedio del segundo bote ay qué feo
problema porque sé porque chocan qué
mala onda ahora en fin a ambos salen al
mismo tiempo y se colisionan entonces
más o menos el tiempo que viajaron es el
mismo llamemos a ese tiempo t
y bueno no lo sé a ambos partieron al
mismo tiempo y les tomó un tiempo para
estrellarse así que digamos que el
tiempo entre el que salieron y el que
chocaron este ahora cuánto viajó el
primer bote viajo en una velocidad de 23
nudos y le tomó un tiempo t para el
choque así que la distancia que bajó es
de 23 cm así que 23 de velocidad por
tiempo es igual a distancia entonces la
longitud de este lado es 23 stem y
similarmente a este otro no sabemos su
velocidad llamémosle x su velocidad es
equis pero la distancia que el viaje
entonces es de x por t así que x porta
es la longitud de este lado y ahora
bueno veamos si podemos averiguar cuánto
vale x que sabemos sabemos de hecho
varias cosas sabemos muchos datos sobre
esto sabemos que es un triángulo
rectángulo etcétera etcétera conocemos
ángulos
así que si quisiéramos saber cuánto vale
x por t y usar el 23 de como información
bueno veamos este ángulo si usáramos los
75 grados que conocemos conocemos el
lado opuesto cierto
el cual es 23 este así que conocemos
lado adyacente el cual es x porten y
regresando recordar el shock a todas muy
famoso y muy útil siempre que identidad
tiene opuesto y adyacente es la tangente
cierto así que todas todas y decimos la
tangente de 75 a ver lo escribo tangente
de 75 será igual a cateto opuesto lo
cual es 23 23 t
sobre cateto adyacente lo cual es x por
t las t se van a cancelar así que te
sobre t eso es igual a 1 y veamos si
podemos resolver para x así que
multiplicamos ambos lados por equis y
obtenemos x tangente de 75 es igual a 23
luego dividimos ambos lados por tangente
de 75 y obtenemos x es igual a 23 sobre
tangente de 75 y bueno es la respuesta
ahí la tenemos lo logramos y bueno si yo
tuviera que de hecho tangente decente de
75 no tengo una calculadora que conmigo
pero puedes calcularlo será un número yo
creo que bastante grande y de hecho si a
bueno si tienes una calculadora a la
mano poneis 75 y después tomar tangente
de eso y listo pero esencialmente
resolvimos el problemita así que bueno
nos vemos pronto bye